welcome to this five-minute game right
I'm mixing it at the moment between five
and 15 minute recordings and that was a
bit confusing ok got a rillo pass here
maybe okay well that's I don't not so
much looking for an adventure here play
my tried and trusted clothes I wear this
to capture I am that's not a very
exciting line to be perfectly honest
Queenie one year okay this attack tv5 so
I needed to enter protected maybe he
wants to play on somewhat quick cook
young before they are interesting
interesting here ok I'm going to take it
yeah well it's a position where I have
two bishops which of course I like but
it's a bit of a cluttered piece
configuration at the moment and also
here that's really a question should i
keep my bishop get it to f8 I think I'll
do that it's it's something that can be
tricky but because the night is so
strong here and the bishop won't be too
but I want to go Bishop an item c5 and
try to take it with this Bishop the rook
is opposite the Queen which is very
important
so if I go 95 now yeah you know told
that I do that
threatening Bishop f5 so I think he
probably will move the night now
yeah okay it's not easy but he's taking
quite a while here yeah well this is a
possible move of course so I guess I'll
take it ya know not much choice but what
now exactly this is an interesting
question his see cuts he has got some
slight development issues Knight c3
might be answered with 2492 I just take
so it cannot so easily develop if I go
Queen D Phi for example attacking the
pawn yeah maybe just stone centralizing
if it takes on g7 Bishop takes f6 I have
Creed d 4 i'd take f6 oh this is not
working at f6 I just play g6 if you take
CA theoretically speaking you might take
can take c7 but ok I just thought that g
six is good yes but I have to have Queen
D for check isn't this check isn't this
quite good and now let's let's consider
I can take here but maybe Bishop d6 is
also move first making sure that you
cannot yeah that you cannot take here on
c7
hmm now if i take f6 next movie has no
good discovery i think i mean most
discoveries just give away be too so if
you go screen g5f 96
yes if i take it now to see have a good
discovery yeah I don't see it night a
for maybe at night a for I can even
answer with Bishop b5 it's not bad
really yeah but should be five is the
easiest
but I'm threatening we should be five so
it's not quite clear to me what is
movies yeah but should be five I guess
all night it's naughty for a problem no
maybe 94 94 takes Fe form and then let's
not let's not so comfortable queen is
seven rock t7 no better not better not
okay so what about let's say 26 yeah try
to get Queens off no yeah well I can go
now Bishop e7 to f6 sssss comfortable
now be sure to g7 yeah this looks okay
can play rook e1 then Queen f6
the good thing about this this extra
point is not that only it's being an
extra pump I'd also controlled some
important squares like c like d fire for
example that's very useful um okay need
to fight for dat
young to e6 yeah probably I cannot but I
can also take here first this is quite
good actually yeah Queenie one is made
no check he has risen to jakes to take
with the night but then i can hear i can
just take take care of everything else
fails maybe Queenie to is also move
queenie queenie one I mean to anyone
also also pretty good am yam should also
should also win yeah the problem was I
think that f6 was not a good idea here
maybe okay already gives me a pretty
substantial advantage the comp I have
simply the better development I thought
here you should retreat just here and
this is of course a very a very solid
position for white he's got nowhere
pawned weaknesses and and no particular
problem can I can't do something like
that I mean it's I think about equal
maybe maybe it's about equal I mean I
would rather play black because of my my
bishop pair thing but still it's a very
very solid structure when we when we got
here look II to assault sins that the
computer likes very much understandably
so I mean it's very directed the text of
the c2 pond and okay well it's very
tactical already this this is very
strong this computer recommendation that
pretty much puts them into disarray
immediately not very good yeah okay well
this I didn't consider only I saw that
this centralization is quite good at a
text the porn here and he cannot easily
develop his pieces it's a matter of
development and coordination and well
here it's they're probably various good
good ideas
but this is so I think pretty convincing
so now we have I mean this this was very
obvious but or the computer actually
points out f4 it's also interesting I
thought that this was a problem but of
course it's a tactic yeah it's it's all
about tactics rook 88 is strong I only
saw that now I don't have a really good
square for the Queen let's say here this
rocket is seven and it's not really not
really great but I have this strong this
is really strong based on the week back
rank and black is an excellent shape but
he could actually play this so I was
right to do not play Bishop b5 but for
the wrong reasons and this was just the
keep it safe the keep it safe kind of
approach it always kept an edge but
wasn't really killing alright thanks for
watching